I'm getting a chance to play the remake
of dead space in 4k I'm really excited
but at the same time kind of scared you
know I'm a wuss when it comes to horror
but I'm excited to check out the science
the medicine the health issues that
occur in this game of which I'm told are
plentiful huge thanks to EA for
sponsoring this video let's get started
I'm sorry
I'm sorry about creeping
I just wish I could talk to someone
it's all
falling apart here
believe what's happening that's her
Nicole yeah first deferred from her in
weeks
we're five minutes out you still got
that thing on repeat
unless you really miss her
this humor is not a job you turn down
this game already feels really realistic
not just because the screen and the
graphics but also because her controller
is vibrating like crazy I feel like I'm
part of it and I'm actually wearing a
heart rate monitor along with the
pulsoid widget because I want to know
what my heart rate's going to be
throughout this game oh I'm already at
106. you know it's serious I've had some
caffeine USG ishimura this is the
emergency maintenance team of the USG
Kelly responding to your distress call
coming issues they're really calm if
they're responding to a distress call
the stress call equals problems
never
come on someone picked up the damn phone
uh those are monsters sounds like their
communication array is busted or maybe
it's Evil zombies
the docking
oh I'm losing control okay I feel like a
trauma situation is about to occur and
I'm gonna turn on my sports med mindset
my ABCs of trauma Airway breathing
circulation oh they're gonna crash I
hope they're wearing their seat belts
and they have airbags in this thing okay
it looked like it came to a pretty slow
stop
I don't imagine there are many injuries
broken
a broken ankle is a problem better than
a broken neck
that's a little bit of an understatement
I guess if I had to choose between a
broken ankle a broken neck I go with a
broken ankle but not if I want to escape
from zombies oh here we go
oh I like his outfit yo look at the
triple visor that's like extra NFL let's
go follow the security okay no idea
where the security team went this is a
very friendly sign here welcome aboard
but nothing about this seems friendly
and welcoming how are these people not
concerned no departure scheduled that's
pretty ominous where's the security
detail those are all great questions my
pulse is going up I'm at 96.
loud noises
ventilation's up power to the elevators
I don't like red there's steam another
malfunction no quarantine systems are
all fine there's a biohazard logo that's
never good
oh
what is that thing how do I get out
come on
no
no why is my guy looking back
sick
I don't know what I am help me
help me
why can't I kick why can't I shoot why
do I have why is my pulse 105. what are
these things called Tim necrom
ancy Necromorphs oh plasma cutter
how did he know those two pieces attach
and that piece of tensions
oh that looks cool cut off what does it
say
cut off their limbs you know what I
always realize in these games the
flashlight actually messes with you
because it makes it more scary like you
could only see where the flashlight is
so everything that's not lit is really
scary
I just shoot oh
how do you keep how do you cut off its
limbs I kind of want to see the anatomy
of these Necromorphs can I pause this
let's look at the Necromorph oh okay so
I have some images here these are humans
that have been turned into Necromorphs
so like I understand the Jaws missing
and there's a hole in the skull but like
you could see the anatomy is very
different than a human because there's
no separation between the deltoid muscle
the bicep like everything is just fused
into one if you look at this guy he has
an arm coming out of his stomach and the
back of the neck has some sort of Razor
sharpness to it and then you have this
other one that looks like a little
lizard that one looks more like a human
minus the canines have greatly expanded
the spinous processes of the vertebrae
are really protruding now by the way you
know you have those like if you tilt
your neck down and you feel c71 you
could feel a bump there if I was a
Necromorph I would look like this guy
we need to get to the bridge there's a
thousand people on board someone will be
there we can't the tram system is
wrecked everything's locked down because
of the quarantine also there's an
important distinction to be made here
this isn't a quarantine this is an
isolation quarantine is when you aren't
sure once you're already sick now you're
on isolation and I'm pretty sure these
Necromorphs are already sick so let's go
ahead and start calling it an isolation
as opposed to quarantine oh
oh you saw that one shot one opportunity
is that even a zombie or is it just a
dead human body oh
what did I just do
oh what is that dude
stasis will slow down enemies and
fast-moving objects
oh you saw that there's actually nothing
like that in human medicine although I
guess you could call like platelet
Inhibitors or blood thinning medications
as stasis inducers whoa whoa okay wait
shooting in the dark right now this
outbreak started on the Colony after the
miners dug up some artifacts I feel like
we've ruled out viral infection here
because the only way a virus can come on
an artifact and then infect others is if
there's like blood on it or
transmissible body fluids that were
infected and then those people were
exposed to it I can't even imagine an
object leading to dementia unless that
object happens to be like radioactive or
something where it's directly damaging
brain cells I think I cracked the issue
more as much I reports they're a [__]
horror show these things mold any dead
tissue into a new form the only life
form that exists like that that I can
even think about is a maggot because a
maggot feeds on dead tissues and then
uses it as energy and function for
itself and we actually use maggots on
dead tissue like if we have a burn or
some kind of infected wound you could
put maggots to chew off that dead tissue
in the flight control room please found
her up here now
there's still a way out for us but we
don't have much time how'd you get here
you cleared the way I can always count
something's freaky not this he's
definitely dreaming maybe this was a
delirium caused by the artifact that
then once you leave the artifact you no
longer have the delirium and remember
hallucinations and dementia don't always
go hand in hand you can have
hallucinations and not have Dementia or
you could have dementia so bad that you
have hallucinations there's different
types of hallucinations there's
olfactory there's auditory visual so
like one type of hallucination may
appear different to another person
okay that was scary but these memes are
legit funny so click here to check that
out and as always stay happy and healthy
huge thanks to EA for sponsoring this
video
foreign